the prices of petrol and Diesel have hit
a record high in Pakistan the increase
will see petrol selling at one dollar
for a liter up from 64 cents this is the
second hike by the government in the
past two weeks Pakistan has recently
signed a three billion bailout deal with
the international monetary fund but
inflation has soared and its currency
has lost value let's get more on this
we're joined Now by ashfactola who's an
economic analyst and former minister of
State for Pakistan and he's joining us
live on Skype from Karachi thank you
very much for your time
Pakistan is already facing one of its
worst economic crises just how much
strain is this increase going to put on
people who are struggling with the high
price of basic commodities
thank you very much uh basically in last
one month the petrol prices the brand
has increased by eight point one four
percent and our currency has been
devalued by nine percent so when it we
add the top two it comes to around
twelve thirteen thirteen thousand and a
half percent and overall increase in the
price is 14 so it is correlated with
that and knowing the international
mechanism of pricing and as we we are in
the IMF program we have to follow the
suit as you already said that we are in
I am a program and we have just been get
a rescue plan of 3.2 billion dollars we
have to adapt to all conditions which we
have agreed upon so this is one of it uh
basically we have not we have not
increased the price we have just
mitigated the factors of devaluation of
currency and international increase in
the price and all of which all of which
has an impact on many people who as
we've mentioned asked struggling with
the High Cost of Living which they
cannot afford and as you said the
increases are in line with the fiscal
obligations that Pakistan must meet in
that loan for three billion dollars with
the international monetary fund now
three billion dollars doesn't scratch
the surface of what Pakistan needs but
are the conditions to borrow that amount
are they going to do more harm than good
to Pakistani people
uh when you're right in a way but we
have to follow the suit what we have to
do now we have to just go and Trigger
the direct subsidy to the people I mean
the social safety net has to be
increased and we have to expand the
wings of pro ability and income support
program we have to increase the monthly
stipend or honorrhea from 5000 to 10 000
that is the only way one can protect the
unprotected people uh yes of course this
is adding the miseries to the normal
life of average Pakistani but I think
this is an international phenomena and
obviously the government has a challenge
now the scaretaker set up as a challenge
to how to cut this inflation yeah and
you're talking about
um
but you're talking about increasing
stipends for people who really need it
where is the government going to find
this money and on the point that you
were just coming to about the government
the second petrol price hike in two
weeks could it have political
implications for the government just
months before a general election
of course it will be having a serious
effect on the political part of the
system but as far as I am concerned we
have recently compiled a report on tax
reforms and we have we have identified
uh new tax Avenues which is direct tax
worth 2.3 trillion Pakistan rupees so
what we have to do we have to we have to
do tax reforms vigorously we have to
follow it and we have to introduce some
measures to test the riches and to give
relief to the Poors that is the only
recipe but as far as Pakistan is
concerned we have got a huge base of
parallel economy so my recipe lies in
manage parity and no interest rate this
is unfortunate that we are in IMF
program and we cannot go for the right
recipe for the people of Pakistan okay
that is the economic analyst former
minister of State for Pakistan joining
us from Karachi thank you very much for
your thoughts